kult cowboy lucky luke mit mehr als 300
millionen verkauften heften ist lucky
luke der erfolgreichste western comic
weltweit gezeichnet wird er seit fast
zwei jahrzehnten vom franzosen hervé
damen tom künstlername steht der
renommierte zeichner lebt in
südfrankreich mitten in der natur
der wilde westen ist es zwar nicht
trotzdem lässt sich stehe hierfür seine
arbeit inspirieren zwischen palmen
bananen und zitronenbäumen dem mit akten
hengst namens obelix und dessen freund
einem esel wenn ich zeichnen muss
entspannen nicht diese momente wenn ich
zu meinen fernengel füttere oder mich um
meine bäume kümmere
das sprechende pferd jolly jumper und
sein besitzer lucky luke sind
mittlerweile alte bekannte für steht
doch das war nicht immer so er musste
sich erst daran gewöhnen die beliebte
comicfigur zu zeichnen
der einsame held der die verbrecherjagd
und den armen und benachteiligten hilft
wurde 1946 vom belgischen zeichner
morris kreiert der bagger steht
persönlich darum sein erbe zu übernehmen
eine echte herausforderung
am anfang habe ich darum gebeten sechs
monate lang erstmal üben zu dürfen ich
fand mich gar nicht gut
ich musste erst drei comic alben machen
erst dann war ich so weit zu sagen ich
bin der zeichner vom lucky luke von 1955
an hatte asterix autor rené goscinny die
texte verfasst seit seinem tod 1977
wechseln die autorin die letzten drei
wände stammen vom franzosen guillaume
soro alias man könnte das ganze als
produkt betrachten um geld zu verdienen
dass der verlag diese figuren
weiterleben lässt obwohl die autoren
längst tot sind
aber für mich muss das einen sinn haben
natürlich will ich dass der lucky luke
den ich darstelle seiner tradition treu
bleibt aber ich will auch einen lucky
luke der von heute ist und in seiner
jetzigen form noch nicht existiert hat
im neuen band fackeln im baumwoll feld
spielt erstmals ein schwarzer eine
hauptrolle
sheriff des riffs kommt mit lucky luke
zu hilfe
die figur hat einen authentischen
charakter als vorbild das neue album
wurde jedoch nicht etwa von der blätter
bewegung inspiriert autor jules begann
mit seinen recherchen zu diesem thema
bereits vor vier jahren
[Musik]
ich habe entdeckt dass 25 prozent der
cowboys schwarz waren und der großteil
hatte spanisches vorfahren der cowboy
den hollywood uns jahrzehntelang
präsentiert hat mit blauen augen aller
john wayne das war eine reine erfindung
im neuen band geht es um die rassenfrage
in amerika die sklaverei ein grausames
und tragisches thema dass ich trotzdem
mit leichtigkeit und humor angehe und
die action darf natürlich auch nicht
fehlen denn es bleibt lucky luke heikle
themen sind zwar durchaus erlaubt
trotzdem müssen die autoren ein paar
regeln beachten
es gibt drei dinge die verboten sind man
spricht nicht über die sexualität von
lucky luke es werden keine toten gezeigt
selbst wenn das heute möglich wäre auch
in der kinderliteratur
aber es passt eben nicht so der club und
er raucht nicht mehr
1983 hatte sich das rauchen abgewöhnt
normalerweise arbeiten autor und
zeichner gemeinsam etwa zwei jahre lang
an einem comic
juli in paris und in südfrankreich sind
ein comics an den leser wenn es action
gibt aber auch ruhige momente
man kann nicht die ganze zeit texte
lesen man braucht auch pausen sonst
steigt der leser irgendwann man muss ein
gutes gleichgewicht finden wie im film
eine pause für lucky luke gibt es
dagegen nicht das neue album ist zwar
gerade erst erschienen doch die arbeit
am 100 band der jubiläumsausgabe hat
längst begonnen